special Council released his finding
today in a hastely arranged news
conference President Biden addressed a
special Prosecutor's report I was
pleased to see he reached a firm
conclusion that no charges should be
brought against me in this case
correcting media claims that he'd been
found to have willfully retained
classified documents this these
assertions are not only misleading
they're just plain wrong refuting the
special Prosecutor's remarks about his
memory and mental acuity angered in
particular by the claim that he couldn't
remember the date of the death of his
son Bo how in the hell dare he raise
that frankly when I was asked the
question I thought to myself wasn't any
of their damn business in his report the
special prosecutor Robert her described
the president as and I quote a
well-meaning elderly man with a poor
memory claiming that Biden could not
remember the date he was appointed vice
president by Barack Obama White House
lawyers describe these comments as
inappropriate and in some cases
inaccurate initially though President
Biden himself focused on another part of
the report I was especially pleased to
see special counsel make clear the Stark
distinction and difference between this
case and Mr Trump's case Donald Trump
and we're talking about many more
documents at issue with Mr Trump
willfully
obstructed and
indisputably lie through his lawyer in a
letter to the Department of Justice
Donald Trump posted on his social media
about what he called a two- tiered
system of justice the house Republican
Judiciary Committee tweeted the
following President Biden couldn't even
remember when he was
VP taking a question on Gaza President
Biden inadvertently gave his opposition
more ammunition as you
know initially the president of Mexico
CE
did not want to open up the gate to
allow humanitarian material to get in he
was referring to the president of Egypt
not
[Music]
Mexico the Rus nature of the news
conference ass signed that debate about
President Biden's mental accurity will
not go away neither will the fact that
the single case against him has
concluded the several against Donald
Trump are going on Mike Hannah aler
Washington
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz